hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bonbon
now bonbon has absolutely dick diddly to
do with Bonnie from five nights at
Freddy's this is another horror game
about something that I don't know but
apparently you get a gift and apparently
I'm going to bread but apparently you
get a gift and that gift I believe is
named bonbon so a little bit like tattle
tale in a way I suppose but then again
that's all my guests so I don't actually
know what's going on here okay zap
bonbon should I become I'm a baby I
think I'm pretty sure I'm a baby
oh hi bonbon how are you doing play with
play with wobbly dog oh I have
telekinetic powers apparently give
wobbly dog a big push wrote a wobbly say
[Music]
I'm a wrote a wobbly dog - did nice
doggy
there's a good doggy alright I'm gonna
give you a big fish oh okay gave wobbly
dog a big push oh oh
carrying toys is hard work for little
hands remember you can throw and push as
well hooky then huh
find all four balls and put them inside
the house for mummy I don't like this I
got suspicions about this right now is
this a ball which is one of those bouncy
boners Oh
Pouncy hopper that's close hello okay I
don't think that's one of my balls oh oh
you're trying to hide for me huh okay
I'm gonna remember that in my nightmares
all right damn aah
so I'm so wimpy who's actually barking
over there and I like that shut up yo
I'm a toddler don't you know that I can
wreak havoc ooh I fell apparently sent
our version of a dog that's horrible
okay all right all right you take care
of yourself now you hear all right see
you around the bend anything in here
whoo I can crawl in I didn't even think
I was gonna be weird yeah okay anyway
okay I've only found three of the balls
the last ball hello boats are loaded
one or two who okay okay gotta find the
last ball unless you count them about
hello hi welcome to my backyard how are
you doing good to see you and such as
the like as that what the hell
hi oh okay you have a ball in your hand
I don't like any of this
hi okay alright like it even less now
I'm just gonna give it a big looks like
I got a face job hello hi oh you're so
fuzzy you're so fuzzy I think I'm gonna
die oh hello oh you're bonbon okay I got
an achievement for that I'm a big brave
boy I'm a big brave boy where did that
ball go yeah Oh mr. orange what are you
doing all the way over there
see you bored bored well done looking
after your toys time to go inside oh is
it oh oh is it oh okay alright alright
I'm inside now I'm very happy about that
conundrum
alright
[Music]
okay all right what is older hello tiny
man no find all four rubber rings do I
get an achievement for like saying I do
everything okay why am I doing this why
why am I doing this
good bye peewee okay I found it donut
all right
found a blue ring mom are you proud of
me yet mom mom I found I can't move I'm
very tired I can oh where do I put this
do I put it over - I put it over here
what no okay oh no it won't let me okay
ashtray monsters do not why are you
saying it's so slow and weird like that
one tiny man oh hello hello voice such a
good good kid all right
rayray Redrum Redrum Redrum
mom mom Redrum
mom I'm screaming right Rob again come
on shouldn't you be at least concerned
about my safety do I need to put the
rest of my toys away uh not miss hey get
in there mr. wiggle worm Oh
Oh
[Music]
the monster blocks oh I'm such a good
diligent little brat
I put away everything look at me go what
whoa okay that was scary you just I
don't know why you did that okay
all right then hello wobbly uh oh there
you are
no I saw you okay I was going hi hello
hi okay hi bond what do you got there
bon bon you got you got tiny people
oh why I don't like this I don't want to
play with your tiny man bonbon I just
you know um Oh
bonbon you are you are just a world a
concern right now did I throw that tiny
man up there because if I did I might be
boned three where's last tiny person
he's one of the first people I found so
uh bond do you have something in your
hand on barnman bonbon please well thank
you well I just I was about to mom I was
going off for darkness I don't wanna
yeah I do I got it is it bonbon it might
be barn barn hello welcome to my
birthday apparently ah look at that
hello mr. Chad my my vision seems to be
an X or ibly drawn towards something on
this goodbye then oh wow okay cake you
want cake
my god you I'm trying to that's some
disgusting drew don't look at me like
that you are more bom bom bom bon bon
bon
no no bon bon bon bon bon you got a
problem why hey whoa whoa easy there
easy no no no
Hey okay all right you know what maybe
maybe it might be a good idea how about
no how about yeah yeah oh it's bad idea
oh it's a bad idea it's a bad idea how
can you tell what's a bad idea
boy okay all right okay all right there
you go pon pon you happy yeah you're
very happy okay I guess I got it
all right let's rip that off of there
don't worry I'm gonna get the I'll go
get the next one
you ready yeah hungry baby goodness
gracious
I can't give you any more on how to
reach Baba get it for yourself
welcome Baba what do you want for me I
literally can get bun-bun what I owe mr.
chatter bye yeah here we go
you want mr. chatterbox Oh
skittle yeah alright okay okay okay okay
the DYFS i don't know i got going okay
all right that's no good
rodent problem it's very large
problematic once upon a time there was
an old Miller who had two children who
were twins the boy twin who's named
hands and he was very greedy the
girlfriend was named Hilda and she was
very lazy
Handy's and Hilda had no mother because
she died was giving birth to their third
sibling named Engel who had been sent
away to there's a great story dad
even when the Miller went away to the
market one day Hans was especially
greedy and Hilda was especially lazy and
the old Miller wept with anger as he
locked them in the cellar to teach them
to be good let us try to escape and
lived with the gypsies said Hans agreed
while they were looking for we as a big
brown rat came out from behind the log
pile
I will help you to escape or ensure the
way the gypsies captain said the big
bear
if you bring me all of your father's
great so hands know they waited until
their father let the miles and the next
day go in the Miller went to market and
left the children locked up inside the
mill they carried all the grin down to
the cellar the big brown rat gobbled up
the grain until there was none left and
then went to sleep behind the log pile
when the Miller came home and found out
he declared that he was ruined and that
they were all starved today and he
looked the children in the cellar and
wept with fear as he turned the key this
is a very weak waiting I only hope the
boy child to escape and show him the way
to the Jupiter's camp big brain right
because the go child was stay behind to
be my wife come back wouldn't you've
organized the wedding once I've escaped
[Music]
so Hans and Hilda waited until their
father welcomed and the next day when
the Miller was out bartering for new
grain they made the trail of breadcrumbs
all round the Merlin into the cellar be
sure the wedding guests were to go they
took the most important pages out of the
hymnal so that the priests had the right
words to say then they stole the meal is
best Sunday jacket and taking the
shoulders so it would fit hands and who
stole their mother's wedding dress and
took up the hem so that it would fit
Hilda and she put it on and she looked
lovely boy in the Miller returned for
markets and saw them dressed up in the
wedding clothes he wept with shame as he
beat them and threw them both into the
cellar once more the wedding guests were
already assembled they were mice and
voles and stoats in the congregation the
choir was made up of crows who were
already singing the Registrar was a big
fat spider with spectacles on and the
priest was a long gray weasel he was
busy rehearsing the right words from the
hymnal hands walked Hilda down the aisle
and the big brown
the reason said the US a reminder that
he would rescue her
I do say the resource ed you take this
innocent young hand for your very own
angle monstrous wrath baby I do said the
big brain right before anyone interrupts
their now pronounce you man and wife
squeak the result as quick as he could
and then a flash over the wedding party
scattered and hands in Hilda were left
alone with the big brown rat I don't
understand sir pens the big brown rat
pushed hands through a secret tunnel
that led down to the river bank the
hands escaped and ran off and became the
beggar boy of course never found his
brother never rescued what older died
was giving birth to a beautiful with her
every 13 baby rats that's not a good
story at all dad let me just lay my
sweet baby addressed what the hacking al
okay why not this okay
all right why not this whatever this is
I am so perturbed ah hello what are you
hello like bug okay we're gonna go over
this way now all right that is not a
good story where am I why am I in here
what okay I feel like that story might
have been Wow all right then low gravity
I suppose that's also an option
ah this is terrible you ever look around
and you're like oh yeah
no wobbly dog what did you do well
okay
you know what I'm just gonna just stop
saying hello to everybody because I
think that's my main problem here okay
well I didn't want to go that way anyway
so what are you doing tiny lady okay
alrighty then anytime you can you can
drop that bad be nice oh okay
alrighty then oh wait a minute
something's different something
something different camp oh I can't
place my eyes upon it
mmm okay alright well this is fun okay
you know what that's great that's good
ah hello wobbly dog you're all better or
something sure thing okay are you go
that way
say uh hopefully say a never but alright
the hell is going on here this might be
one of the weirdest yeah I thought that
was bonbon this might be one of the
weirdest games I've played in recent
history alrighty then well hmmm
barn barn
okay this guy trying to escape I'm very
slow one but that's okay right
I'm very slow at this okay
ah bonbon there's there's really no need
for any of this
bonbon truck trying to hide
oh look light bug right hey bonbon I'm
just gonna come out and say it
I know it's an unpopular opinion err I
know that everyone's gonna roast me in
the comments but I just don't like
bonbon I'm gonna say that a lot I just
don't like him
bonbons a bit of a dick okay
hmm hmm okay that's that's not good
whoa whoa ah you got short stubby arms
no I'm not going towards it
[Music]
[Music]
never been more confused about a game in
my life
Borat but hey that's the perspective of
a child I suppose so anyway that was bon
bon that was a that was good I mean
honestly it was good in that it
engrossed me controls were a little
wonky because it's an indie game and
it's a little like unpolished but still
like I was engrossed the whole time I
wanted to know what the hell was going
on it was so weird having bonbon just
there from the very GetGo standing there
and you just stumble upon the bonbon
so either way that was really fun hope
you guys enjoyed it I'll leave a link to
the game in the description below let me
know what you thought down in the
comments down there thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]